[Music]
the first way to break the wall down and
this is very important is someone
previously went through the same issue
that you're going through and they made
it so one of the keys is finding others
who have overcome the issues that you
are facing that gives a person a sense
of hope
I say this a lot that hope does for you
what what would think with when you can
use hope when you don't have a product
you can use hope when you don't have a
real solution so hopefulness starts
building your resistance to this idea of
bitterness and stagnation so you need to
have a hopeful outcome and that hope
normally it's triggered with someone who
says I firm where you are but I know how
to get you past it I know where we can
go beyond it now then that may take a
Syrian you know I don't get too
theoretical but we used to call the
impact compression sometimes you need
impact impression that causes you to
wake up and say okay well maybe maybe
this is what you know you you know some
people call it an intervention or maybe
you need some series of ideas or maybe
you need an awakening but there has to
be this moment where it affirms that you
are not alone see if you think your
problem is very unique you you you
believe that no one else can understand
that other than you so you gotta have
some people to say no no no and I get
that I get that and it makes sense to me
and but but but they don't but that's
not all that's just the beginning and so
you got to then travel over this arc of
how you move past these small nuances of
of you know hurt and pain that keeps you
kind of constrained impact impression is
a young man who is operating in a
lifestyle that's negative whether it be
drugs whether it be whatever the case
and someone who he loves it's killed
instantly
well well how do I respond to that do I
now become a killer do I you know what's
what what's my
my immediate is a fighter flight is it
and any stoves
it's those you know lit up moments those
pitches that become permanent scars or
permanent marks on your thought process
I mean I used to be good but man I
realized you know our death a loved one
who turns on you you know those things
that really cause you to wake up now
it's in those moments that someone has
to be there to say wait a minute let me
let me let me reorganize what you're
looking at and then me let me take you a
little deeper because if not you're just
you're either use it as a way to to gain
momentum and negative a negative ground
or you'll use it to get yourself help
get yourself whole again so that no
those are impacting friends I mean I man
I cannot tell you how many young people
when I interviewed them when I went to
prison their first interview they would
say I was just doing this and then my
board called me all this you know they
were not that day was just like Winston
was just like teased it but it but
something happened that Wednesday that
changed every other wins for the rest of
their life but that's the impact in
person
[Music]